today the Matt wall show the most
popular YouTube star on the planet is
Now featuring a transitioning man in his
videos Mr Beast sidekick Chris Tyson has
a wife and a child but has still decided
to start a medical gender transition
quote unquote it's a sad case but
several important lessons can be learned
lesson number one is to stop letting
your kids watch Mr BEAST's videos also
James O'Keefe has an explosive new
report about the efforts to send violent
male sex offenders into women's prisons
a United States Senator casually
declares war on Russia over Twitter Joe
Rogan comes out in defense of Bud Light
and Daniel Radcliffe grovels before his
LGBT Gods all of that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
battle has finally left DC and is going
to the Grassroots as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in a post-role
America with one million Volunteers in
1500 cities 40 Days for life holds
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities because of that they've
actually been uh they've been a larger
presence in blue States especially in
California since the first 40 Days for
Life campaign took place in 2007 they've
reached over 1 000 cities in 63
countries former abortion clinic
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no show rate to go as
high as 75 percent which is detrimental
to their business thank God for that
these law-abiding vigils have helped
close abortion facilities in San
Francisco Seattle and Chicago they're
also leading the way in efforts to
prevent pharmacies from dispensing
chemical abortions so support their work
and check out their locations uh their
podcasts and their free magazine at
40daysforlife.com the fight for life is
far from over in fact it's never been
more important than it is right now so
for more information on 40 Days for Life
go to 40daysforlife.com
we live in a segregated culture and I
don't mean segregated racially though
the left is certainly working on that I
mean that it's segregated generationally
the younger Generations have their own
culture their own language their own art
their own music their own Universe to
themselves which exists almost entirely
online it shouldn't be like this and it
wasn't always like this but in the
internet age this cultural bifurcation
of young and old is only getting worse
and kids have their own celebrities too
these are people who gain tens of
millions of fans even hundreds of
millions of fans young fans and become
household names for younger people so
they're household names among the the
children in the household but not the
adults while remaining almost entirely
Anonymous to anyone over the age of say
30 or 25. a prime example of this is
YouTube Star Mr Beast and the YouTuber
known as Mr beast real name Jimmy
Donaldson has 145 million subscribers on
the platform that's just that's just for
his primary Channel Donaldson also has
several offshoot channels each boasting
millions of additional subscribers on
his main Channel Donaldson has three
times as many subscribers as Taylor
Swift twice as many as Justin Bieber in
fact he has more subscribers than every
pop star more than every internet
personality more than every Media or
Entertainment Company aside from Sony's
India division that one hasn't beat but
other than that
he has the most he is he is massively
successful wildly famous
and yet I hadn't heard of him until a
few months ago I spent much of my day
online for my job unfortunately I also
have a YouTube channel of my own which
feels suddenly quite obscure by
comparison but I've only just recently
become Vaguely Familiar with Mr Beast
and even now I wouldn't recognize the
guy if he passed me on the sidewalk it
is to say the least very troubling that
someone can become this prominent among
younger generations and have this much
influence over them and yet be so
obscure to the rest of us
if you're a parent and you've made the
mistake of giving your child open access
to the internet you're placing an
enormous amount of faith in these
influencers who are influencing your
kids
it is a faith that is almost always or
really always misplaced because even the
most family-friendly content the most
seemingly innocuous as most of Mr
BEAST's content appears to be
can subtly or not so subtly introduce
Concepts
that will take your child down a very
dark path in the case of Mr Beast that
path has been opened by his sidekick and
co-star on his videos named Chris Tyson
Tyson's a frequent collaborator with Mr
Beast an internet celebrity in his own
right with nearly 14 million subscribers
across Tick Tock Twitter and Instagram
and he appears in many Mr beasts videos
it's very familiar to fans of the
channel
and those fans most of them kids again
have been watching over the last few
months as Tyson has transformed himself
from a married man with a child to
something that is supposed to look like
some sort of approximation of a woman
fans had noticed for several weeks as
Tyson underwent a sort of bizarre
physical change not only growing his
hair out but beginning to appear
increasingly frail and sickly and
started wearing women's clothes and all
the rest of it finally last week Tyson
came out as trans and confirmed that
he's been on hormone replacement therapy
for the past two months
explaining his decision Tyson tweeted
quote informed consent HRT saved my and
many others lives the hurdles GNC gender
non-conforming people have to jump
through to get life-saving gender
affirming Health Care in a first world
country is wild to me just let people
make informed decisions about their own
bodies
in response to uh the concerns some
people have raised about the effect his
transition quote unquote might have on
his young son Tucker Tyson said quote I
know I'm going to be a great parent and
so is every other person who puts the
love of their child before everything I
made this decision because I wanted to
show up as my best and happiest self for
him in a way this was for Tucker
now we'll return in a moment to the
grotesque and laughable claim that he's
destroying his body and denying his own
manhood for the sake of his son for the
sake of his son he says he's doing it
but first we have Mr BEAST's own
reaction to all of this yesterday he
sent out a tweet
blasting those who've raised concerns
about having a transition in quote
unquote man appear constantly in videos
meant for kids he called it absurd and
said that called the concerns absurd
that is and said that all this
transphobia is starting to piss me off
now admittedly
Mr Beast has been put in an extremely
difficult situation because he built a
multi-million dollar Empire with
innocuous family-friendly content
targeted at kids and now his friend and
collaborator and sidekick has decided to
turn these videos into a sort of visual
Journal of his gender transition
so Mr Beast has a choice he can either
kick Tyson off of the team and then be
excoriated as a transphobe or he can
come out fully in favor of
transgenderism and he can stay therefore
in The Graces of the the good graces of
the media and LGBT activists even if it
means alienating a huge portion of his
fan base
especially the parents of his fan base
well unsurprisingly he chose the latter
and now that he's gone down this road
there's really no coming back you can
expect much more pro-trans content from
Mr Beast going forward which means that
if you're a parent and you allow your
child to watch Mr Beast videos now is a
very good time to stop allowing that
we could probably assume that Mr Beast
would prefer not to have to deal with
this but Tyson has forced him to make a
choice and uh and he chose and he chose
wrong
this is really the common thread Tyson
is forcing this onto people who are
close to him forcing it in more ways
than one a few months ago Tyson posted a
photo of his young son in high heels
with the caption quote Tucker chose to
slay this morning
it's only a matter of time we could
assume before we start hearing about
Tucker's own quote unquote gender
transition Journey a journey which Tyson
will claim that Tucker chose for himself
but we can clearly see who is making the
choices here as for his wife Katie we
can surmise how she feels about all this
based on the fact that she is divorcing
her husband
Tyson announced just a couple of weeks
before coming out as trans or non-binary
or whatever that uh that he and his wife
had separated and were working on quote
unquote finalizing things so if you're
keeping score at home
Chris Tyson has destroyed his marriage
abandoned his child to a broken home
created huge problems for his friend and
business partner potentially costing him
millions of subscribers and therefore
millions of dollars and he has done all
of this
just so that he could live out his
fantasies in public
he had a beautiful wife a child a family
an incredible job that most people would
kill for which had made him wealthy and
famous and and he pulled the pin and and
chucked a hand grenade into the middle
of that happy and Serene picture and for
what
all so that he can be his quote happiest
self he claims
and he achieves his happiest self by
rejecting his actual self
and all the responsibilities that his
actual self is Duty bound to fulfill
now Tyson is of course just the latest
in a long line of grown married men who
decide to come out as trans or
non-binary this was Rachel Levine's
story this is really a story of some of
those prominent trans activists in the
country I think grown men who transition
after they've already had kids and and
are married this is a demographic that
is uh that is vastly over represented
among trans activists
now we know that you know a great many
of the people who identify as quote
unquote trans you know you're talking a
lot of this there's this is a because of
Rapid onset gender dysphoria and the
social contagion Factor there's many
adolescent girls who get caught up in
this
um but when it comes to the activists
it seems that a hugely disproportionate
number of them are men
and especially Men Who quote unquote
transitioned when they were already
adults so Tyson is then a valuable
example because he reveals an important
truth about the trans phenomenon
despite what we are so often told
the decision to transition is not
personal and private
okay it's not some sort of harmless
personal decision it's not like you're
you're you know choosing an ice cream
flavor at Baskin Robbins
okay that's a decision where you can
rightly say to anybody who has an
opinion about it hey this doesn't affect
you okay what do you care
that's not this
you're doing something that will have a
dramatic life-altering devastating
effect on those who are closest to you
this is not a private Journey that you
walk alone you are dragging others with
you whether they want to go or they
don't and almost always they don't
indeed all of Western Society has been
dragged into this we are all impacted
and profoundly so by individuals who
refuse to accept reality and live as
themselves
but those who are closest to the uh
impact site will feel it the most
and many of them will end up buried
under the rubble
starting first and foremost with the
families
this is why a you know a grown man like
Chris Tyson
who makes this choice
really does not deserve our sympathy or
our understanding
I know saying that will probably get me
in trouble yet again with many on the
right who say well we've got to be
sympathetic and nice about this
um not to these people
because he is engaging in the ultimate
Act of family wrecking narcissism
it is the deepest betrayal of his
marriage vows
of his responsibility as a husband and a
father
and even worse he's dismantling his
family in a way that Society approves of
which means that his wife can't object
to the total demolition of her family
and her marriage she can't cry out in
anger or sadness while her husband takes
a wrecking ball to her life
without being labeled a transphobe and a
bigot
which is probably why she's remained
silent through all this as far as I know
she hasn't said anything publicly
she's not even afforded the Dignity of
her grief
she is deprived of the right to be angry
about this terrible thing that has been
done to her
okay you're a grown adult man you have a
wife and you transition that is
something you are doing to your wife
and to yourself but also to your wife
a man who has an affair you know and
leaves his wife for another woman at
least that guy has the decency to wreck
his marriage in a way that allows his
wife to hate him for it and her anger
will be validated by Society
men like men like Chris do the same kind
of thing yet they do it in a manner that
calls for the wife's understanding
you know very often we hear about men
who transition with their wives alleged
support and yet the details don't really
add up so for example a woman named
Deborah tweeted this to me yesterday in
response to one of my tweets she said
quote my best friend Katie transitioned
with the full support of her spouse and
in fact they still live together even
though they're officially divorcing not
everyone has the same story this is
quite a beautiful story I'm proud to
have Katie as my friend
hmm
um
yes his spouse fully supports it she
thinks it's great
I mean really she's so happy about it
she really is also on a totally
unrelated note they're getting a divorce
because that's obviously what you do
when your spouse makes a decision that
you absolutely support you divorce them
for it
obviously the claims about supportive
wives are always fictional in these
cases I mean always
that in every case
when a married man decides to quote
unquote transition the wife does not
support it and I don't care what the
wife says about it publicly she doesn't
support it and I know that because
these women married men
okay they didn't marry some kind of
vague ambiguous notion of a person
they didn't just say oh I'm marrying a
person it doesn't matter what they are
or what they look like or anything just
it's just a person
no they married men
with definite characteristics both
physical and not it is a form of
Abandonment the worst form in fact to
intentionally strip away and attempt to
change everything about yourself that
your wife thought she married
I mean to to deliberately attempt to
become the opposite of what you are and
what your wife married
it is again an extreme betrayal of your
marriage vows
you are taking your wife's husband away
from her you're taking your child's
father away from him
and the best you can do to justify that
decision is to say that it makes you
happy
so even by your own telling even
according to your own rationalization
you are choosing your happiness over the
needs and desires and the happiness of
your family
see here's the thing
here's the thing transitioning is wrong
always and every time uh first because
it's impossible you cannot transition
from one sex to the other but even if we
lived in the sort of Science Fiction
Universe where such a thing was possible
it would still be wrong to do it when
you're married and you have a child
like if I believed in the reality of
transitioning I would still say that by
the time you get married and conceive a
child the transition ship has sailed
it is your responsibility now it's your
obligation to suppress that part of you
and live as the man that your wife and
child need you to be
but it's not possible
and so the reality is so much worse
you're setting it all on fire you're
burning your life to the ground
in pursuit of something you can never
Attain
that you had something you had something
real and beautiful and now you have
nothing nothing but a fantasy
figment of your imagination
but but at least you're happy right
but even your happiness is fake your
happiness is as real as your Womanhood
you aren't happy
nobody is now
that was a trade-off
and it's never worth it
now let's get to our five headlines
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that's why you need to
check out Helix mattress I've had my
Helix for years now and I absolutely
love it night after night I sleep like a
sweet sweet baby and I want the same for
you but you need a helix mattress for
that Helix has a sleep quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences the
perfect mattress for you because why
would you buy a mattress that was made
for somebody else the quiz asks I'll ask
all kind of questions about your uh your
sleep preferences whether you're a side
sleeper or a stomach sleeper all these
other questions and then they match you
with a model that's right for you go to
helixsleep.com Walsh take their two
minute sleep quiz to find the perfect
mattress for your body and your sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free Helix has over 12 000
five-star reviews and you can find out
why by going to helixsleep.com there are
flexible payment plans make it so that a
great night's sleep is never far away
for a limit time Helix is giving you 20
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners but you got to
take advantage of this of this amazing
offer at helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix
better sleep starts now
we begin with a report from James
O'Keefe who's on his own now but still
covering extremely important stories
like this uh the daily wire reports
quote James O'Keefe released a video
Thursday evening in which two female
inmates at the Washington State
Correctional Center for Women
discuss male inmates allegedly abusing
the system by claiming to be transgender
O'Keefe said that the wccw has been the
tip of the spear with inclusivity in the
prison system as he went on to explain
that OMG news which is his uh his new uh
outfit went to Great Lengths to protect
the identities of the two women by
significantly altering their voices and
blurring out their faces the video
identified the inmates as inmate number
one and inmate number two it was not
clear how or when the interview was
conducted
um quote
so we have men rapists men murderers
child rapists men who have killed women
and are in prison for raping and killing
women who get put in our rooms in my
number one claimed imagine coming into
your room one day and your enclosed
custody and you turn around and there's
a man standing there peeing in the
toilet because you have the bathroom in
your room and CC and CCU there's nothing
you can do
I know there's some having sex with
women there was some like assaulting but
no one reported it inmate number one
said actually we have the video which is
a little hard to understand because of
all the The Voice alteration that had to
do to protect the anonymity of these
women but uh we'll we'll watch a little
bit of this
briefly
men who have killed women and are
imprisoned to Awakening human
James O'Keefe OMG news here have you
heard of the Washington State
Correctional Center for Women which has
been in the news for its policy to place
men who identify as women in the same
prison sometimes even the same cell as
biological women
[Music]
name
what you just heard and what you're
about to hear are multiple inmates
describing their experiences with
transgendered women formerly known as
men within the women's prison
wccw has been the tip of the spear with
inclusivity in the prison system to
protect the at-risk individuals involved
we've taken steps to conceal the
identities of the sources and the
inmates
you have
civilizations are always going to apply
no matter what institution
but somehow in this institution they are
adapting ways to prohibit
presentation
so they're prohibiting segregation based
on sex and these prisons is what she's
saying like I said a little hard to
understand there because of the because
of how they you know the Great Lengths
here to uh
protect the identities of these women
for obvious reasons more for the daily
wire uh quoting uh the inmates inmate
number one said that some of the men who
are getting put into prison by claiming
they were transgender we're doing so
just so they could have sex with female
inmates
well there's nothing you can do but say
you're going to kill yourself and then
go down to the crazy unit to get out of
that room it may number one said and if
you refuse to go back in there you get
in major uh you get in major trouble I
told all this to the assistant secretary
yummy number two said that normally in
Correctional institutions people are
segregated like sex offenders usually
sex offenders are not in general
population they're always in the
population of Their Own my safety is now
in Jeopardy she says because I cannot
voice my freedom of speech but that
doesn't apply anymore because now
they're implementing this new gender
equality role that forces us to conform
to what they want us to believe in about
the transgenders
amen number two said I've heard some of
these men talk about how they would want
to get a girl pregnant so the girl could
form a lawsuit against wccw and say that
he raped her and he's willing to go
along with it he's pretty much the
Mastermind behind his own Scandal
um
I mean it's it's hard to put in we're
into words just how evil this is it is a
direct violation of I mean common sense
and basic human decency but also the
Eighth Amendment
you know which is a guarantee against
cruel and unusual punishment it's
definitely cruel and also certainly
extremely unusual
to lock women in prison cells with
violent dangerous men
and these women are totally vulnerable I
mean they are defenseless voiceless
they can't do anything about it they
can't they can't say anything they can't
do anything
even by these two women by speaking out
behind the blur behind the uh The Voice
alteration still there's a chance that
prison officials could find out who said
all this I could find out where this
came from maybe and they can um you know
they could they could either enact
reprisals themselves they could feed the
information to the other inmates to the
male inmates that these women are
complaining about
um putting their their lives uh you know
in Jeopardy and so they put their lives
on the line
in in a certain way and are aware of
that by speaking out
which is quite heroic I mean we we know
how
difficult it is for women and for girls
who are on sports teams and locker rooms
to speak up against it because we know
that you know what what they can face
just look at what Riley Gaines faced
well now take that exact situation
except the women are in prison and have
no rights at all
this also really reveals the leftist
um
victimhood hierarchy and all of its
hideous confused Glory right because
here you've got female prison inmates
many of them are women of color as the
left would say many of them coming from
poverty you know statistically speaking
a lot of these come from poverty and and
and though the the non-violent offender
in prison thing that's kind of a
certainly exaggerated
look at all these non-violent offenders
well it's exaggerated when it comes to
men in prison
you know a great proportion of the men
in prison are violent but in women's
prisons it's actually true that many of
them are non-violent offenders because
men and women are different and they
commit different kinds of crimes not to
say that women can't be violent
but the majority of women in prison are
there for drugs they're there for
property crimes uh they're there for uh
public order offenses as they're called
so you could not ask
for a group that seems to tick off
more victim categories right it checks
off more you could ask a group that
would seem to check off more of the
victim categories you have
non-violent poor black female
prison inmates
so you would think that that would be as
victimy as you can get as far as the
left's concerned and yet they are
superseded entirely
by trans
just think about this a white a white
male convicted rapist
takes priority over a non-violent poor
black female
by this equation
if the white male says that he's trans
if he remains a male and admits that
he's male and well he has no choice but
to remain male but if he if he you know
says that he's male then uh then he'll
you know remain all the way to the
bottom but all he has to do is say oh
I'm a woman and that's
do not you know do not pass code not
collect like that's that's uh you're
going right to the top
actually I just confused that Monopoly
analogy but never mind
um he takes such a priority that in fact
the very life of the woman
doesn't matter to the left her life her
safety
all of that is sacrificed
the what the left is saying is that it
is it is worth it to them
it is worth it to them
for a woman to get raped repeatedly
in a prison cell
for the sake of affirming the transdude
that is directly and explicitly what the
left is saying
because we have yeah
male sex offenders male rapists
you put them in a jail cell with women
it's it's not hard to predict how that's
going to go
and people on the left they know that
and what they're saying is well hey it's
a risk worth taking
for the sake of affirming this trans
person
it's just uh
it's
as I said it's it's really impossible to
fully capture just how Wicked This is
we have Justin Pearson who's the
Tennessee Democrat um Tennessee Democrat
pretending to be an abolitionist
preacher from the you know uh 1850s he
was reinstated in the Tennessee House
Representatives yesterday and first of
all here he is coming back
um coming back he's coming out to the
house floor after being reinstated and
uh here's that scene let's watch that
experience
[Music]
there he is there he is pumping his fist
waving through the uh cheering crowd
except that the crowd is not cheering
everyone's ignoring him
he's standing there hey everyone yes and
everyone is just ignoring him
um
and if that wasn't cringy enough to
watch
you know every video involving this
clown is a uh is a try not to cringe
challenge really it's like how long can
you even endure watching this before you
have to look away because the cringe is
so intense so if that wasn't bad enough
here's Pearson a few days before this
get again doing his uh doing doing his
his whole act this whole shtick let's
watch that
[Applause]
what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah In This Moment
all right turn off
as far as I can go it's as far as that's
the most I can endure
um
you know I'm far from the first to
point this out but
it's worth pointing out anyway
that that part of what we're dealing
with here
it's a bunch of dorks okay a bunch of
theater kids from high school
and they wanted to be actors but they
couldn't hack it so they became
politicians instead
that is the Tyranny that we are under
these these washed up theater kids
who wish that they could be you know
acting in something on Netflix but it
didn't work out and so they're doing
this instead
and I would rather I would I would if I
had to I'd prefer not to be under any
tyranny at all but I would rather have
the Dignity of being oppressed by like
old school dictators than these cringy
little embarrassing nerds I mean if
you've got if you have to have it if you
have to if you have to live under a
tyrannical system
I think I'd prefer I prefer the former
over this
all right speaking of uh
tyranny uh Democrat Senator Joe manchin
paid his honorary visit to Ukraine and
um you know he made the pilgrimage as
all elected Democrats must make and many
elected Republicans as well are making
their pilgrimage to uh to you know go to
zelenski and bow before him and all the
rest of it so let's watch some of the
video that he posted and then I'm going
to read the caption that he wrote for
this video which he posted to uh to
social media but first here's the video
watch
[Music]
the determination and the skill
and the will of the Ukrainian government
and Ukrainian people and it's our
pleasure to be able to give them all the
support we possibly can go back home to
America be able to explain our
commitment to basically show the support
okay that's enough of that who cares
that's fine here's the caption
he says in my lifetime I have never seen
the United States of America in a more
just War
our purpose is to defend freedom and
fight for democracy and that's why we're
supporting Ukraine every step of the way
as they defend their country and their
way of life
so did you get that
um we are in a war
the United States is in a war a U.S
senator just announced casually on
Twitter
that we are at war with Russia
now you might say well we already knew
that
yes but they have not announced that
they've in fact they've denied that up
until now
they've denied that we're that the
United States is involved in the war
we're not going to get involved all
we're doing is supporting Ukraine we're
sending money uh in all the right that's
what they've been saying up until now
and now we get the United States Center
just casually saying yeah we're at War
we're at war with Russia
you know uh constitutionally the a
declaration of war is supposed to be
made by Congress
and we got we got away from that decades
ago who cares about the Constitution
and then it went over to presidents can
just on their own decide hey we're going
to war with this uh country
and now even that is too formal I guess
and now any politician could just
declare it on Twitter hey guess what
we're at War
there's a line in one of the most recent
episodes of succession where Logan Roy
R.I.P uh spoiler sorry says to it says
to his kids I love you but you're not
serious people and that's how I feel
about our politicians except for the
love part I I don't love them so it's
more like I despise you
and you are not serious people these are
not serious people
um they're doing serious things
so that's what makes it so dangerous
that we have unserious people
like Justin Pearson we just saw a bunch
of washed up theater kids we have
unserious people who are involved in
very serious things
so they do things like
get us into a war with a nuclear power
and then announce it on Twitter like
it's nothing
and the media a bunch of unserious
people as well they don't even they they
treat it as nothing
there's no follow-up questions you know
nobody's asking hey wait a second
Senator are we at war is that so you're
this is official now
is that what you're saying
no follow-up questions everyone that's
okay whatever
you know I mean the whole Ukraine thing
our involvement in it is not serious I
mean it's serious in the sense of being
catastrophic for our country it's
serious in that way
but they have no serious reasons for it
okay it was it was not a it was not a
a decision that was seriously considered
this is not the result of serious
contemplation and discernment or debate
at all
um
just something that we
decided to do without any serious reason
the only reason we've ever been given
are the the platitudes that we just
heard from Joe manchin there
we're defending freedom fighting for
democracy
okay democracy is a it democracy is it's
a it's an abstraction okay it's not what
do you mean fighting for democracy it's
it's it's a form of government
that we have in this country in name
only
but that's not the kind of thing you
fight for
you don't go to war for that
for democracy
as if Ukraine one of the most corrupt
governments in the world to begin with
as if they're some sort of shining
example of democracy
and even if they are you don't go to war
for abstractions you don't go to war to
defend like the concept of a form of
government
that is not at least in a in more
serious times in countries governed by
serious people that's not what you do
all right
here's another uh episode of headline
versus reality so the New York Post has
this headline
one in five U.S adults has had a family
member killed by a gun
this is the uh and this is the headlines
making the rounds by mainstream media
it's just nearly one in five adults in
the U.S say they have a relative who was
killed by a gun a disturbing new study
revealed Tuesday the troubling statistic
included death by Suicide according to
the report from the Kaiser Family
Foundation a similar amount 21 of
respondents said that they had been
personally threatened with a gun the
study also found that people of color
were disproportionately
disproportionately impacted by gun
violence with three in ten black adults
and one-fifth of Hispanic respondents
saying that they have witnessed someone
being shot
okay
so let's go through the problems here
you have the headline one in five uh you
know that our our uh have a family
member who was killed by a gun
number one they don't they don't specify
what they mean by relative so are we
talking about fifth cousin twice removed
is that is that a relative
um so what do you are we talking about
immediate family
because if we just mean every you know
one in five people have someone related
to them somewhere down the line it was
killed by a gun well I'm sure it's I'm
sure it's like five out of five people
okay
now you get into like the Six Degrees of
Kevin Bacon type of situation except
with guns and so if if you're extending
it out
um
and there's no limits put on what counts
as a relative then yeah I mean
everyone's connected
in that way
so they don't specify that
and they also as always and this is
something to remember when it comes to
these gun violence statistics
they include suicides with guns
and this is a a cynical dishonest
really pretty gross attempt to to beef
up it's you know that we're patting the
stats of gun violence by including
suicides
when of course you know when you say gun
violence no one thinks of suicide they
think of homicide so every time you say
suicide every time you say gun violence
you are putting in people's minds the
image and intentionally you're putting
in people's minds the image of you know
uh murder and attempted murder that's
whenever anytime you say gun violence
that's what everybody thinks of
and yet a huge portion
of those statistics what you call gun
violence it's neither of those things
these are suicides
now yeah the end result is the same
somebody is killed
but a homicide and a suicide are are
different things
um
because of course in in one case you
have someone who is
you know killed by another person using
the gun to kill them the other case you
have a a tragic choice that somebody
made to take their own life and also
you know it's it's absurd enough to
think that
you can um
solve the problem of homicide and
violence
by passing gun laws it's even more
ridiculous to think that you can solve
the problem of suicide by passing gun
laws
you're going to stop people from killing
themselves with gun laws
even if you could find a way to get rid
of all the guns in the world
that's not going to stop anyone from
committing suicide if they want to
commit suicide
trying to stop people from committing
suicide is a very noble cause that we
should be doing that but you don't do
that by just taking away one of the
unfortunately many Avenues a person can
use to take their own life
and then there's also this absurd
nonsense about 20 21 of the people in
the country have been threatened with a
gun 21 percent
just
not believable nothing about this is
believable so if if you want to have we
keep hearing oh we gotta have a serious
conversation about gun violence in
America
okay okay let's have a conversation
about about violence
let's have a you know I'd rather have a
conversation about violence in general
because there is far too much of it in
this country especially in our cities
and if you want to talk about that let's
talk about it but can we start by being
honest
can we start on on an honest playing
field can we start with the reality and
then go from there
next we have Joe Rogan who's chimed in
on the Bud Light story and had a take
that uh Solomon maybe didn't expect
we'll listen to a little bit of this
yeah you want a beer I'd take a light
okay let's get some Bud Lights Let's uh
do this yeah in support of Bud Light in
their time let's be allies by getting a
little District we're going to be allies
yeah you know because Kid Rock and
Travis Tritt have put the hammer down I
know they're really fighting the good
fight man here's my take okay
like what you're do what you're doing
what they're doing is just spreading the
brand to uh an extra group of people
yeah why if something is good do you
give a
who's got it
like when we do this with cheesecake
like you know what I'm saying like if
there was like a bomb ass cheesecake and
all of a sudden you know some radical
group like antifa really got in the
cheesecake would be like this yeah
and if the like if the Cheesecake
Factory sent antifa cheesecake you know
for 10 more years of chaos
celebratory that's celebratory yeah if
only Isis had bear claw Donuts yeah I'm
still eating those on the other hand I
loved Kid Rock's video because I love
that I love Cheers Cheers man I love
that kind of thinking
not even that I agree with it
I like wild people yeah I like raising
hell man I like to do to take some
machine gun to a stack of Bud Lights
it's like Anheuser Bush this will
show up but I mean where's he gonna go
now you're gonna go to Coors don't they
all support like uh LBGTQ plus AI
whatever the hell else they're at
attaching to IT issues I will do I mean
I'm from caller so
so I mean I do admire the acting skills
required there to uh take a a sip of Bud
Light on camera and pretend that you're
not repulsed by it but so let me I if I
could uh let me explain why we care
nobody's complaining about trans people
drinking Bud Light okay if they want to
subject themselves to Bud Light then um
then if they want that punishment for
themselves go for it
that's not the point
the point is that Bud Light is promoting
transgenderism They are promoting the
idea that a man can be a woman
and they're promoting it by celebrating
a man's day 365 of girlhood
so
they're promoting a lie a harmful toxic
dehumanizing lie in fact the example
that uh Joe Rogan gives there is is a
good one he says well what if okay what
if antifa decide to eat cheesecake does
that mean does that mean we're not going
to go to The Cheesecake Factory anymore
well no if if some antifa group decided
to eat on their own to go buy a
cheesecake obviously it's not going to
stop anyone from eating cheesecake for
the second example he says well what if
Cheesecake Factory sent a a cheesecake
to antifa and said congratulations on
all the chaos yeah that would cause me
to not eat a Cheesecake Factory anymore
uh yeah that would because there's a
difference in one case you have a group
of people that have decided to buy this
product fine in the other case you have
the company officially endorsing
what these people are doing and and that
is a difference there's a difference
between a difference between people
using the product and the company
officially saying I agree with what
these people do I think it's great
and yeah so it's it's exactly that same
sort of thing in fact
Bud Light putting Dill Mulvaney on a
beer can
is really exactly the same sort of thing
as Cheesecake Factory setting a
cheesecake to antifa and saying
congratulations on uh on burning all the
buildings or whatever
um
and in both cases
you know the customers will be upset
about that and they should be
like why would they be
you you have you're a powerful wealthy
Corporation and you have decided to send
a message
you're using your power and your wealth
or the power that you gain from your
wealth and the wealth that you gain from
the customers to send a message to the
culture and the people who are giving
you that money are going to say to
themselves well uh do I do I like this
message
and if they don't like the message
they're gonna say oh I don't want to
contribute to the message I'm going to
stop giving you my money it's a really
simple there's there's nothing extreme
about this
the only thing that makes this uh
unusual or makes it into kind of a
bigger story is that
uh well for one thing that the thing
that Bud Light is endorsing in fact it
would it would even though they're
similar
situations it would be it would be
better
for Bud Light or a Cheesecake Factory to
endorse antifa than to endorse
transgenderism because at least antifa
exists okay that's an actual thing that
exists
and so by endorsing antifa you're
sending a lot of harmful messages but
it's not really an assault on just like
reality itself whereas by endorsing the
idea that Dylan Mulvaney is a girl not
even a woman but a girl that Dill
Mulvaney is an adolescent girl like he's
pretending to be you are uh sending a
lot of harmful messages but you're also
it is also you're partaking in this
assault on reality
um
and so the but the only thing that makes
it unusual is apart from that is that
usually conservatives
will just continue handing their money
over to corporations who will then use
that money
to uh work against them in the culture
to fight against them
and to promote messages and ideas that
those same conservatives abhor
now on the left they don't they don't do
that as much if a company comes out
opposed to them and what they believe
it's uh it's a pretty
you know it's for them it's a pretty
easy decision to make
but on the right we've just gone along
with it and so now in this one case
finally
conservatives are saying you know what
no I don't need Bud Light in my life it
you know and if this is what you're
going to do then
piss off
and whether you agree with Bud light's
messaging here or not I think it's uh it
should be pretty easy to understand the
justification for uh you know why this
boycott is happening and must continue
to happen
you know the only thing that calls off
the boycott is if Bud Light comes out
and apologizes
and also renounces their previous
support for
the idea that men can be women
if they do that then I would say
absolutely not only would I say drink
Bud Light if they did that I would go
buy I don't even drink Bud Light I'd go
buy a case of it myself
if they did that
you know the boycott is to is a
consequence
but if the company does the right thing
and backs down then yeah they should be
rewarded for finally doing the right
thing but until that happens
the boycott is on and it stays on it
stays in effect
let's get to the comment section
for a day
there's someone to think you need to
sleep baby game
Biden's plans to help struggling
business owners in the wake of coveted
lockdowns were of course to prioritize
black latino Native American and
women-owned businesses because without
saying that if the roles were reversed
if Biden had said his plans were to
prioritize white male loan businesses
there would have been outrage but if you
own a business no matter what
demographic group You Belong to You
Can't rely on the government to bail you
out you need to take matters into your
own hands and Innovation refunds can
help you do just that if your business
has five or more employees and manage to
survive coven you could be eligible to
receive a payroll tax rebate of up to 26
thousand dollars per employee through
the employee retention credit just go to
getrefunds.com Innovation refunds has
helped uh has already helped clients
claim over three billion dollars in
payroll tax refunds through the ERC and
they may be able to help your business
too it's not alone there's no payback
it's a refund of your taxes there's no
upfront charge either they don't get
paid until you get paid uh with your
refund don't let this opportunity pass
you by see if your business qualifies
for ERC assistance in just eight minutes
go to getrefunds.com click on qualify me
and answer a few questions this payroll
tax refund is only available for a
limited amount of time don't miss out go
to getrefunds.com getrefunds.com
Anna Powell says my brother had a very
similar experience with a woman in the
Air Force ROTC program he's a part of
she claimed he assaulted her at our
house a very small modular home that
struggles to adequately fit four people
at the time we had nine people there for
a holiday three guys on the couches one
on the floor two women in one room me
and my own and my parents in theirs I'm
not sure how she thought she could get
away with claiming that she was
assaulted with literally no way of it
conceivably happening and thankfully she
did not win in the school nor the Air
Force but it was
and never should have happened he's now
five thousand dollars in debt with his
name smeared through the mud and uh and
now that he has cleared she gets to walk
away as if nothing happened pisses me
off
um
yeah and and that's why to me
it's very obvious that
the policy should be
you know if you falsely accuse someone
of a crime of any crime really whether
it's rape or any other crime if you
falsely accuse somebody of a crime then
then you will be given the same
punishment that they would have been
given if they'd actually done it and
been convicted
so um you know false rape accusers
are treated by the justice system just
as rapists are treated
and that's how it should be now
if if this was the case then it couldn't
be that you know a man's falsely accused
and then he's acquitted or the charges
are dropped and then automatically the
the uh the woman goes to prison no it's
it's a separate crime and so now she
should be charged and uh and now you
have to prove her her guilt in a court
of law
um
but that ought to be the policy there
has to be a real penalty for this
right now there's like there's no
penalty so if you've got a woman who has
no Integrity she's manipulative
just a bad person and you know has no
moral standards at all
and she wants to get back at a guy she
whatever her reasoning is
there's like no incentive really for
someone like that to not
there's no disincentive when it comes to
a false accusation for a woman
you make the accusation
um
maybe maybe it ends up with the person
you're targeting going to jail and
because you're a terrible person you'll
love that even if they don't go to jail
well you've still you've still as you
said drag their name through the mud
you've ruined the reputation they they
have to live with the false accusation
for the rest of their lives even if
they're innocent for the rest of their
lives they're still going to be that guy
who was accused of this
and um
and there's no consequence for you
whatsoever so
why not do it that's what
these women think that's why there has
to be a real consequence
Katie Mills says Matt shouting out 90s
kids in the yo-yos and virtual pets give
me a Nostalgia Buzz I remember having a
mini yoyo and big one in my pockets
going to class in elementary school I
miss when toys taught you a skill it
took skill and hand-eye coordination to
get those yo-yo tricks I had to go to a
library or rent a video to learn those
sweet moves I remember a time when
learning a skill and striving to be the
best was mainstream and unifying
and actually cool
um I'm glad to know that the yo-yo thing
was uh was was more widespread I was
never sure if it's like this weird
blip on the radar screen of my childhood
there's this there's like short period
of time when everybody in my school it
was mostly mostly the boys but but all
the boys had yo-yos it was like the
coolest thing and it but it went away
very quickly
and I always wondered was that just was
that just where I lived or was it a
Nationwide phenomenon apparently it was
but you really can't you can't come up
with it with a situation more foreign to
current day kids than what you just
described there uh Katie of
kids playing with going to the library
to rent a video
to learn
yo-yo skills every part of that is kids
today just don't know anything about
um
Ali says I want to know what Matt thinks
about teachers calling students by their
preferred pronouns even if the parent
doesn't want them to just as a teacher
myself I see this creeping in the
classroom and it being just another way
for me to get fired
what do I think about teachers using
preferred pronouns well I
I would imagine you prop if you've
watched this show for even uh for even
you know two and a half minutes then you
probably know what I'm going to answer
to that which is uh I am a hundred
percent opposed to teachers using quote
unquote preferred pronouns
I mean I'm opposed to the the preferred
pronoun concept being recognized at all
the preferred pronouns I don't care what
you prefer the pronoun should reflect
reality and that's all the teacher
should uh
that is all teachers should be concerned
about in general is the reality and
teaching kids about things that are real
and true
um
Cole says one way I know a man is right
about dyl Mulvaney's popularity
regardless of the right discussing him
or not is the fact that my wife knew all
about Dylan before I started talking to
her about him and the insanity around
his life she knew all about him and she
doesn't pay any attention to politics at
all that proves to me at least that
Dylan Mulvaney was going to be a
cultural pillar regardless of what the
right-wing media did
well of course because as we talked
about you know a couple days ago
um when the left decides that they're
going to pick somebody out and make them
a champion make them a martyr make them
a hero make them a celebrity make them a
star uh the left has the ability to do
that they don't need they don't need
anybody's help they don't need all our
help you know it's very flattering to us
to think that they need our help and so
if we don't acknowledge somebody if we
ignore them we put our head in the sand
we look the other way
um that they're just going to disappear
and they're not going to become famous
but that's unfortunately that's that we
don't have that kind of cultural
purchase I wish we did but it doesn't
work that way so the left can say okay
we don't need you people it's we're
still gonna
again we own all of the ins Fame is
something that is
um oftentimes bestowed on people by
institutions you know the powerful
institutions if they take someone and
say we're gonna make this person famous
then they can do it that's it
um and in this case that's what they
said with Dylan Mulvaney also
here's the other thing about this
Dil Mulvaney was already a tick tock
celebrity
before anybody on the right mentioned
him or knew who he was he was a tick
tock celebrity before that I mean that's
why we started talking about it it
wasn't like we picked out some random
person who had five followers on Tick
Tock okay no this he was already a thing
a phenomenon and then the right noticed
and started commenting on this
phenomenon
well what that means you know another
way of saying Tick Tock celebrity is to
say that this was a celebrity among kids
okay again this is the this the cultural
kids having their own culture and so
this is kids already knew about filming
because they're on Tick Tock and so he
was already a celebrity among kids
if we on the right made him famous
if we did that at all we made him famous
to the parents okay he's already famous
to the kids and so we took him and said
hey parents look what's happening over
here okay look at this guy and what he's
saying to kids that's what we did
and yet you have some conservatives who
who what think that's a bad thing
but so you you think it's just better
for the kids to to be influenced by this
person and parents to not notice or know
anything about it
you know this is um
this is a a general principle
that these celebrities
these figures
um
they exist kids are following them
and so we can ignore them all we want
and that's not going to make them go
away it just makes the it just makes it
worse
because now they have free reign and
they can do and say whatever they want
without it without being criticized
if you're looking for something
interesting to watch this weekend check
out our series what we saw hosted by
Storyteller Bill Whittle season one is
focused on Apollo 11 and right now for a
limited time all four episodes are
available for free on YouTube meanwhile
in Delaware plus season two of what we
saw is in full swing and this time bill
has set his sights on the Cold War and
the tension between two superpowers that
lasted for 45 years episode five picks
up with the death of Joseph Stalin as a
newly inaugurated President Eisenhower
has just taken office with Knives Out
for succession in the U.S USSR
um Eisenhower sees this moment as a very
brief window of opportunity to reset the
conflict Bill makes it feel like you are
there in the moment witnessing history
new episodes of Cold War come out every
week but you have to be a member to see
it so go to dailywire.com Cold War to
start watching now now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
ever since JK Rowling was caught in an
act of infidelity having an adulterous
affair with science the left has been
unable to really get over the Betrayal
they've been so enraged on such a such a
single-minded mission to punish JK
Rowling for her dalliance with common
sense that even those merely associated
with Rowling are made to perform acts of
public Penance the entire cast of the
Harry Potter film series have come out
at various points and uh you know they
want to make it clear that that they do
not share Rowling's heretical belief in
biology you know they've been desperate
to Signal their allegiance to the trans
cult we're not like her they cry as they
humble themselves before the LGBT God
we're good and Faithful Servants we what
other basic realities would you like for
us to deny what other bits of
nonsensical gibberish do you need us to
utter on your behalf
well we could put out a statement saying
that two plus two equals green elephants
are made of pudding if you want anything
for you o Lords
Chief among these gravelers is Harry
Potter himself Daniel Radcliffe who um
you know clearly recognizes that he is
potentially the most guilty the most
Guilty By Association as the star of
Rowling's fantasy series he feels called
to speak the loudest about this he must
do the most to repudiate the author's
bigoted belief in reality the result is
that Radcliffe has now taken a public
position that is even more fictional and
Fantastical than the world of wizards
that Rowling created
I mean if Radcliffe had come out and
announced that Hogwarts is a real place
where actual children fly on broomsticks
and learn how to do magical spells it
would have been less outrageous and more
credible than the position he's actually
taken
because instead he's professed to
believe in transgenderism especially
trans kids quote unquote recently he sat
down for a round table discussion with
these alleged trans kids in a video
produced by the left-wing extremist
group The Trevor Project watch
I learned from you know
out of the cradle that I am you know
that I was a boy I should like blue I
should like sports I should be manly I
should like superheroes yeah and I just
I never Associated myself with those
things and we are told that we're not
old enough to know to know this yet like
I mean I'm only 11 years old how do I
know I'm a girl and I need more time to
think about this
he doesn't like blue sports or
superheroes
that's how we know he's a girl
it's not how he decided that he's a girl
I mean he's a child he didn't decide
anything rather it's how the adults in
his life decided for him
so we see once again how the the only
people rigidly enforcing so-called
gender roles are the gender ideologues
themselves they are such Believers and
Generals they so firmly insist that boys
must must like boy things quote unquote
that anybody anybody who doesn't like
those things is labeled a Girl by them
this is a you know gender role
reinforcement taken to grotesque
extremes
it's something that the most Avid
right-wing believer in gender roles
never would have even considered
I myself believe in gender roles that is
I believe that there are certain roles
certain attitudes and behaviors that
Society should expect from a person
based on their sex I believe that that
doesn't mean that someone who rejects
those roles isn't a member of the sex
anymore
also when I talk about gender roles I
mean like more important things like we
should teach boys how to be protectors
and providers you know that kind of
General I couldn't care less if they
like superheroes or the color blue
who gives a damn about that
so the gender ideologue not only
ruthlessly and violently enforces gender
roles but in forces specifically the
most Superfluous and meaningless ones
by the way I know something about boys
who don't care about sports or
superheroes I'm raising two of them
right now
both of my older Sons are are only you
know nominally interested in superheroes
and neither of them have shown any great
interest in sports aside from you know
shooting Hoops out of the in the
driveway on occasion but my
nine-year-old son prefers to build forts
in the woods that's what he likes to do
my six-year-old prefers to follow his
older brother around and annoy him with
whatever he's doing that's basically his
hobby right now
um what's the significance of their lack
of interest in sports and superheroes
there is no significance it doesn't
matter
okay I mean I I'm as conservative as you
can get when it comes to these issues
right and I embraced that like I said I
I embrace the fact that I oh gender we
don't want gender roles I fully Embrace
gender rules I think they're a good
thing
but even I with my own Sons I'm not like
well you need you sit down and watch
Batman you have to watch you have to
like Batman you're a boy
I don't do that nobody does that
okay nobody cares that much about it
there are many ways to be a boy this
this is the truly accepting view of the
matter
so it's the left who declares that there
is only one way and any boy who exists
in any other way is kicked out of the
boy club
let's continue
but there are also people who do have
like a slightly condescending but
well-meaning attitude of like well
people are young and like how do we you
know there is a huge decision I'd love
to hear from all of you about like why
we can trust kids to like tell us who
they are well I just feel like well me
and you kind of share like a similar
story I transitioned like super young I
came out to my mom and well not telling
her I was trans but told her that I was
a girl at the age of six it's been like
years like what I've lived female more
than I've ever lived male so like I just
feel like it's just living proof that I
obviously knew who I was just like
everyone else does
I don't understand why I can't just
decide that I'm a girl I if it's a big
decision to decide on my girl it's a big
decision to decide I'm a boy right it's
just it's the same thing there's no
there's no age you don't have to be 18
to decide that oh I am who I am I think
we don't give children enough credit for
coming into this world and having a
sense of Purity and understanding for
themselves like
um I definitely had that at a very young
age and I tried to express that a lot
but I grew up in like a very
stereotypically Christian family okay so
like me telling my mom any type of me
being different was like oh my God like
literally she called my grandma and they
prayed over me I was like seven
and like at that very moment like it was
very like fearful like fear striking but
like at the same time if we're going to
be able to like have relationships and
be authentic with each other this is
something that I need you all to get you
know yeah but I would love to hear from
you also about just like as I said like
I always knew I was a boy because it was
just a thing that I grew up knowing yeah
yeah
um so everything that these kids are
saying is is nonsense it's gibberish one
of the kids says that the fact that he
announced his fictional female identity
when he was sick somehow proves that
it's legitimate but I believe this when
I was six is not a convincing defense
for literally any proposition
six-year-olds believe lots of things
about the world and themselves that are
not so this is one of the Hallmarks of
Early Childhood it also has been one of
the most you know has been had been one
of the most charming and joyful things
about childhood the fact that kids are
so innocent and oblivious
but the left has exploited this
innocence in the most Insidious kind of
way the other boy says that choosing to
transition into a girl
isn't a big decision any more than it
would be a big decision to choose to
remain a boy that's like saying that a
nine-year-old choosing to be a
commercial airline pilot isn't any more
of a big decision than choosing to not
be a commercial airline pilot just
because one decision is Big doesn't mean
that the reverse of that decision is
also big
of course my analogy doesn't totally
work because it is at least technically
possible for a nine-year-old to Pilot a
plane it's not a good idea but it's
possible it's not possible for a
nine-year-old or for anyone of any age
to become the opposite sex so again this
is all nonsensical but I don't judge
these children obviously or feel any you
know uh contempt towards them they're
abuse victims they've been brainwashed
they've been LED down a path and they've
been made to believe that it's a path
they chose and now they are offering
retroactive justifications for this path
that was actually chosen for them and
they're not justifications that they
came up with but rather they are talking
points that they were given and that
they were told to repeat on occasions
like this
so I have an immense amount of sympathy
for these kids
but Daniel Radcliffe on the other hand
is a different story now notice how
Radcliffe ever so meekly pushes back and
attentively suggesting that maybe
somebody might raise and arguably
somewhat valid concern about you know
whether children are old enough to make
these kinds of decisions it's totally
patronizing of course he hastens to add
it's patronizing and they're wrong for
saying it but but uh but you know I mean
how should we respond to these questions
yeah I mean listen Daniel you you know
better
you're only a few years younger than me
you grew up in a world where the
biological reality of male and female
was not in question which is the same
role that every generation of human
beings except the most recent one grew
up in
so they didn't get to you soon enough or
young enough for you to actually buy
this garbage you cannot have been
convinced because nobody's ever
presented an argument in defense of this
stuff it's not that they've made bad
arguments is that they've made no
arguments
so there was never a moment when someone
came along and said to you hey you know
actually little boys can really be girls
and and we should give them drugs to
make them into girls even though they
already are girls but they're girls
invisibly you see and so they're girls
in some kind of uh you know in some sort
of abstract sense and that's what we
need the drugs for
and and then and then and then no one
said that to you and then you said oh
well that makes sense okay I mean you've
convinced me
no that didn't happen because they
mostly sane and moderately intelligent
person cannot be persuaded by
unintelligible gibberish
so there can't be any I get it moment
because there's nothing to get you
weren't convinced by arguments or by any
kind of reasoning process
you were instead like most other adults
on the left convinced in the same way
that you know a um a shop owner in the
1940s would have been convinced to
accept the protection of the mob the mob
doesn't come to a business and present a
proposal a business proposal and then
you know give you a week to weigh the
pros and cons
they extract your compliance through
threat and force
and that is exactly how the LGBT mob
operates
you have been encouraged to promote the
trans agenda encouraged with the promise
that if you don't they'll rip your life
to shreds and and also your career
it's been hard enough for the Harry
Potter guy to get any good roles outside
of the Harry Potter franchise imagine
how hard it would be if the Harry Potter
guy was also a trans Folk
so that's the calculation that you made
you may take comfort in the fact that
you're only going along with this
Sinister Madness because you feel you
have no other choice but you should
realize that every era has its own sort
of sinister Madness and every person uh
who's ever gone along with it has made
the exact same rationalization that you
are making now
and yet we look back on those people
with disgust
they were faced with a test
stand for what's right and true and
endure the consequences or cooperate
with evil for the sake of their own
self-preservation and they failed the
test
and they're defined forever and for all
time by that failure just as you will be
you sat in a room full of child abuse
victims and you applauded their abuse
you are a disgrace and a coward and a
liar
you sold whatever fragments of your soul
you still had left
I hope it was worth it but I know that
it wasn't
because again it never is
and that's why you are today
canceled
and that'll do it for the show or for
this portion shows move over to members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday have a great weekend
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign